[Music]
so
[Music]
at the core what we do is help nhs
trusts and all healthcare employers
to better manage their pool of flexible
workers
through the staff bank fundamentally
reducing the reliance
on agency locums whilst ensuring
that they have a compliant pool of
workers
able to book all their vacancies and
ensuring safe staffing levels
[Music]
hi i'm romy sabova the ceo of pensionbee
the uk's leading online pension provider
we help our customers to combine their
pensions into one new
online plan that they can manage from
the palm of their hand
on their smartphone or on their computer
our customers top up their pensions
they plan for their retirement and
ultimately they make withdrawals from
the age of 55.
[Music]
now more than ever is an important time
to increase
the resilience of our supply chains and
support the smes
that the economy depends on the best way
to do this for large corporates
is to pay invoices fast
our technology plays a critical role in
supporting this
by getting a view of erp data on a daily
basis
we can precisely risk assess each
invoice
in an instant
is an adaptive retail space available to
book by the hour
and personalized to you pick from
sioux's growing network of locations
and bring your vision to life in an
instant with our ultra high res
digital walls from design to staffing
the entire process can be managed
remotely
whether you're based abroad or working
from home souq has got you covered
book by the hour and never pay for even
a minute more than what you need
with our flexible availability and
affordable rent
suk lets you connect with your customers
at the times that matter most
and at a price that makes sense
[Music]
you